>> ASKED HIM IF HE IS EVER TAKEN
THE SUBWAY.
WHEN THAT GREAT TO SEE YOU,
THANK YOU.
SO VERY EARLY ON IN THIS CRISIS,
WE WELCOMED LIEUTENANT GOVERNOR
GOVERNOR OF TEXAS ON TO THIS
PROGRAM.
HE TOOK A VERY DIFFERENT POINT
OF VIEW FROM THAT OF A LOT OF
POLITICIANS AT THE TIME.
BUT HE WAS SAVAGELY CRITICIZED
FOR THAT.
HE SAID HE WAS WILLING TO ASSUME
SOME RISK TO HIMSELF AS A MAN OF
70 THE SAKE OF HIS CHILDREN AND
GRANDCHILDREN.
HERE’S PART OF IT.
>> I’M GOING TO DO EVERYTHING I
CAN TO LIVE BUT IF YOU SAID ARE
YOU WILLING TO TAKE A CHANCE AND
IF I GET SICK, I’LL GO AND TRY
TO GET BETTER BUT IF I DON’T, I
DON’T AND I’M NOT TRYING TO
THINK IN ANY KIND OF MORBID WAY,
I’M JUST SAYING THAT WE’VE GOT A
CHOICE HERE AND WE ARE GOING TO
BE IN A TOTAL COLLAPSE
RECESSION, DEPRESSION AND
COLLAPSE IN OUR SOCIETY IF THIS
GOES ON ANOTHER SEVERAL MONTHS,
THERE WON’T BE ANY JOBS TO COME
BACK TO FOR PEOPLE.
>> Tucker: IT’S BEEN ABOUT A
MONTH SINCE THAT MOMENT, WE
WANTED TO CHECK IN AGAIN WITH
LIEUTENANT GOVERNOR PATRICK WHO
JOINS US.
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR COMING ON.
YOU WERE PRETTY CLEAR IN WHAT
YOU THOUGHT MIGHT HAPPEN IN OUR
CONVERSATION A MONTH AGO.
YOU SAID IF THEY DON’T PULL US
BACK A LITTLE BIT, YOU’RE GOING
TO SEE A LOT OF PEOPLE OUT OF
WORK AND YOU’RE GOING TO SEE THE
ECONOMY COLLAPSED.
DO YOU FEEL YOU’VE BEEN
VINDICATED?
>> I’M SORRY THAT I’M
VINDICATED.
I WISH IT HADN’T HAPPENED BUT
I’M A SMALL BUSINESS KIND OF
BEEN AROUND THE BLOCK LONG
ENOUGH TO SEE WHAT WAS GOING TO
HAPPEN.
WHEN YOU START SHUTTING DOWN
SOCIETY AND PEOPLE START LOSING
THEIR PAYCHECKS AND BUSINESSES
CAN’T OPEN AND GOVERNMENTS
AREN’T GETTING REVENUES AND IT
GOES ON AND ON.
SO I’M SORRY TO SAY THAT I WAS
RIGHT ON THIS AND I’M THANKFUL
THAT WE ARE NOW FINALLY
BEGINNING TO OPEN UP TEXAS AND
OTHER STATES BECAUSE IT’S BEEN
LONG OVERDUE.
THEY TOLD US TO FOLLOW THE
SCIENCE.
WHAT SCIENCE?
AT THE END OF JANUARY, DR. FAUCI
WHO I HAVE GREAT RESPECT FOR US
AS THIS WASN’T A BIG ISSUE IN
THREE WEEKS LATER, GOING TO LOSE
2 MILLION PEOPLE.
NOW IT’S UNDER 60,000.
AND WE’VE HAD THE WRONG NUMBERS,
THE WRONG SCIENCE AND I DON’T
BLAME THEM, BUT LET’S FACE
REALITY OF WHERE WE ARE.
IN TEXAS, 29 MILLION PEOPLE.
WE’VE LOST 495 AND EVERY LIFE IS
VALUABLE BUT 500 PEOPLE AT A
29 MILLION AND WE ARE LOCKED
DOWN AND WE ARE CRUSHING THE
AVERAGE WORKER, CRUSHING A SMALL
BUSINESS, CRUSHING THE MARKETS,
CRUSHING THIS COUNTRY AND THERE
ARE MORE IMPORTANT THINGS THEN
LIVING AND THAT IS SAVING THIS
COUNTRY FOR MY CHILDREN AND MY
GRANDCHILDREN AND SAVING THIS
COUNTRY FOR ALL OF US AND I
DON’T WANT TO DIE.
NOBODY WANTS TO DIE BUT WE’VE
GOT TO TAKE SOME RISK AND GET
BACK IN THE GAME AND GET THIS
COUNTRY BACK UP AND RUNNING.
ONE MAXIM IN THE MEANTIME IN THE
MONTH OR SO SINCE WE’VE SPOKEN,
YOUR STATE WHICH IS IN SOME WAYS
THE MOST ROBUST STATE IN A LOT
OF WAYS AT A 50 HAS REALLY BEEN
HURT.
OIL FUTURES DOWN TO NEGATIVE 40
BUCKS TODAY WHICH IS SHOCKING.
NEIMAN MARCUS OVER 100-YEAR-OLD
COMPANY FROM A TEXAS COMPANY,
DALLAS COMPANY, BANKRUPT.
>> AOC BUT A TWEET UP TODAY THAT
SHE WAS HAPPY TO SEE THE OIL
INDUSTRY COLLAPSE.
WE CANNOT ENDURE THIS MUCH
LONGER.
EVERY MONTH WE STAY CLOSED IS
GOING TO TAKE TWO TO THREE
MONTHS TO REBUILD THAN THE OTHER
THINGS THAT THE PRESIDENT TALKED
ABOUT AND I THINK THE PRESIDENT
ON THE SAME DAY THAT I WAS WITH
YOU ONE MONTH AGO TO THIS MONDAY
NIGHT, WE WERE BOTH SAYING THE
SAME THING.
WE CAN DO TWO THINGS AT ONCE SO
WE LISTEN TO THE EXPERTS AND
DOING EVERYTHING WE CAN TO
PROTECT LIFE AND WE HAVE TO THE
BEST OF OUR ABILITY AND THE
DEATH RATE HAS BEEN LOW.
EVERY LIFE IS PRECIOUS BUT OUR
COUNTRY SHOULD NOT HAVE BEEN
LOCKED DOWN AND NOW I’VE ALWAYS
SAID IF THE DEMOCRATS EVER HAD
TOTAL CONTROL, THEY WOULD PUT
PEOPLE LIKE YOU AND ME IN JAIL
AND THREW AWAY THE KEY.
AND THAT’S WHAT THEY’RE DOING
BECAUSE THEY NOW HAVE TOTAL
CONTROL.
EVERYWHERE YOU SEE THIS
DRACONIAN RULES OF WALKING DOWN
PEOPLE AND KEEPING BUSINESSES
SHUT AND DESTROYING OUR COUNTRY,
IT IS MOSTLY DEMOCRATIC
GOVERNORS, DEMOCRAT COUNTY
JUDGES AND DEMOCRAT MAYORS.
ALMOST EVERYWHERE.
AND WHEN I SAW THE GOVERNOR OF
NEW JERSEY LAST WEEK SAY ON YOUR
SHOW IT’S ABOVE MY PAY GRADE,
THEN YOU NEED TO RESIGN.
THAT’S WHERE YOU PUT THE HAND ON
THE BIBLE AND TAKE OFFENSE.
AND TO PROTECT THE CONSTITUTION
OF THIS UNITED STATES.
DON’T MOCK IT.
SO IT’S TIME TO GET BACK TO WORK
WORK.
>> Tucker: AND NOW HE IS
ARRESTING PEOPLE WHO CRITICIZE
HIM.
LIEUTENANT GOVERNOR, THANK YOU
FOR COMING ON.
I NEVER DEFEND POLITICIANS BUT
THE ABUSE YOU TOOK WAS SO
RIDICULOUSLY, I WANTED TO HAVE
YOU BACK.
THANK YOU FOR THAT.